frau wuppen die frage noch mal nach dem
wegen dieser eigentlich nicht absehbaren
großen worte also sicherheit gegen die
freiheit unsere existenz gegen die
gesundheit alt gegen jung wir stehen
sozusagen vor riesigen dilemmata wie
kann man das einschätzen wie kann man
das wegen und sogar entscheiden
man muss sich die gewichtigkeit und den
ethischen gehalt natürlich auch den
rechtlichen und verfassungsrechtlichen
gehalt dieser güter angucken
ich würde sagen dass freiheit ganz
sicher das höchste gut ist und die wird
im moment sehr eingeschränkt das ist
aber gerechtfertigt denn um überhaupt
frei sein zu können muss man ja erstmal
leben und wenn in einer pandemie so
viele menschenleben bedroht sind und
nach nature an der ba-manager artikel
wenn wir nichts tun würden würden
weltweit 40 millionen menschen sterben
das wäre für deren rechnung also das
steht wirklich was auf dem spiel da das
heißt die freiheits einschränkungen sind
vorübergehend gerechtfertigt aber nur
vorübergehend denn das sind massivere
grundrechtseingriffe religionsfreiheit
also religionsausübung bewegungsfreiheit
versammlungsfreiheit und so weiter und
die müssen wir dann aber wieder so bald
wie möglich reaktivieren und deswegen
ist diese abwägung zwischen sicherheit
und freiheit ist eigentlich eine
abwägung zwischen leben und freiheit und
jetzt neben gerade viele menschen und
das in einer großen gesellschaftlichen
solidarität viele opfer in kauf um das
leben von gefährdeten und schwerkranken
menschen zu retten
aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
auch viele andere noch schwer krank sind
die sind nicht fit 19 erkrankt die
warten jetzt auf ihre chemotherapie
die warten auf eine lang ersehnte
operation die ihnen die schmerzen nehme
oder ähnliches und die müssen wir schon
auch mit in den blick nehmen deswegen
wäre mir sehr daran gelegen und das
liegt auch dem papier morgen mit
zugrunde dass wir nicht nur wirtschaft
und gesundheit sondern auch diese breite
gesellschaftliche situation in den blick
nehmen was macht das mit dem menschen
wenn sie zu hause sitzen
suizidgefährdung überforderung
häusliche gewalt kindesmissbrauch das
dürfen wir alles nicht vergessen bei den
vielen anderen nöten das ist anstrengend
aber ich glaube das müssen wir uns jetzt
zumuten
und dann sind wir wieder bei professor
brinkmann viele fordern jetzt diese
sogenannte exit-strategie aber kaum
jemand traut sich zu sagen wie können
uns dabei die virologen vielleicht
helfen kann man darüber nachdenken dass
man klassen zu unterschiedlichen zeiten
in schichten sozusagen wieder in die
schule kommen lässt kann man darüber
nachdenken home office praktiken die wir
jetzt irgendwie alle gerade lernen und
vielleicht sogar lieben dass man die
beibehält und sagt das ist gut das
sollten wir machen was denken sie ich
glaube das ist nicht nur der job der
virologen das dass es wirklich ganz viel
wir wissen einfach vieles noch nicht der
virologe kann da jetzt auch nur sehr
begrenzt rat geben und es hat sich jetzt
auch nicht groß etwas neues entwickelt
dass ich jetzt sagen kann
kinder sind wirklich keine große sind
sind nicht verantwortlich für viele
übertragungen das wissen wir einfach
noch nicht und das kann natürlich auch
dann die maßnahmen sehr stark
beeinflussen
ich glaube dann müssen wirklich jetzt er
noch auf andere länder schauen und
schauen wie wir haben die das denn
gemacht manche haben die schule nicht
geschlossen dafür haben sie aber andere
maßnahmen eingesetzt wie das tracking
tracing was was jetzt auch diskutiert
wird dass man wirklich weiterhin
großflächig teste die test kapazitäten
wir auf jeden fall noch erhöhen
natürlich und dann natürlich auch
wirklich diese kontakt nachverfolgung
wieder durchführen kann ich denke das
ist auch ein ganz wichtiges und wir
haben irgendwie eine million zuschauer
fragen nun auch zu den berühmten
schutzmasken also österreich hat eine
pflicht dazu eingeführt die stadt jena
auch das rk ii das robert-koch-institut
ändert heute seine empfehlung zu diesen
masken machen oder lassen was sagen sie
ich finde es ganz schwierig etwas
vorzuschreiben die österreich ist jetzt
macht wenn man das material nicht hat ja
also das ist für mich ist die diskussion
da eigentlich schon am ende die masken
müssen im moment zu den personen die
wirklich exponiert sind stark exponiert
und das sind die ärzte das sind aber
auch die die menschen der häuslichen
pflege arbeiten und die alten menschen
abklappern ja die brauchen masken und
das bekomme ich schon auch mit dass mich
leute anrufen und sagen ich bin in der
häuslichen pflege
ich habe keine masken mein arbeitgeber
hat keiner was soll ich tun und von
daher finde ich können wir jetzt nicht
empfehlen bitte tragt alle masten und
man muss sich auch ganz klar auch die
selbst gehäkelten helfen nicht die
selbstgestrickte heute gebeten
das kann man also ich finde ich finde
die initiative gut man muss sie wenn
dann auch richtig nähen und kann ich den
einen zu durchlässigen stoff in einem
fall muss auch beachten sie gäben keinen
hundertprozentigen schutz und man muss
sie auch schon richtig anlegen was man
häufig sieht dass das menschen die
masken einfach nicht richtig tragen dass
die nase rausguckt oder dass die die
öffnung an der seite zu groß ist ja das
sind schon wieder die gepumpte und da
gibt es mittlerweile aber auch gute
videos die zeigen wie lege ich sie
richtig an
und wie lege ich sie auch wieder richtig
ab dann ist man ein bisschen lernen
herzens wie ist es in aachen also auch
in dem stadtbild security vor den
supermärkten fragezeichen haben die
menschen da schon masken auf ja nein es
gibt auch bei uns in der städteregion
viele initiativen selber masken zu
nehmen und die auch auszuteilen das ist
sehr lobenswert da sind leute mit großem
engagement zu gange
wir legen aber nur großen wert eben
darauf auch medizinprodukte weiter in
die medizinischen bereiche zum anlernen
wir haben sehr frühzeitig eine masken
pflicht angeordnet in den alten wohn und
pflegeheimen auch für behinderte
menschen die ja auch oft vorerkrankungen
haben was gerne vergessen wird
da haben wir gesagt das medizinische
personal dort sollte unbedingt masken
bekommen und zwar medizinische masse
also die berühmten fbi wenigstens der
vfb zwei masken im kontakt mit positiven
ansonsten der medizinischen mund
nasenschutz dafür dafür müssen wir die
häuser dann aber auch ausstatten wir
haben also uns auch darum gekümmert wo
kriegen wir das material her wie fahren
wir das dann in die häuser damit die
auch in die lage versetzt werden das zu
tun
und das ist eine herausforderung und ein
deutsches wort ja das ist eine große
herausforderung dieser einrichtungen
dann auch zu versorgen wenn man sowas
fordert und da mache ich mir sorgen
darum wenn solche produkte dann
plötzlich wie in österreich im
supermarkt auftauchen
es ist ja nicht so als hätten wir die
abstandsregelung eingeführt weil die
leute plötzlich schlecht riechen sondern
das ist ja auch ein schutz der wirksam
ist sonst hätte man den ja nicht
empfohlen wir haben auch in den
supermärkten ja schon plexiglas die
leute dort sind ja geschützt und
deswegen finde ich es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir eben noch mal genau schauen wo
gehören medizinprodukte hin und wenn man
dann als geste eben im alltag ein
selbstgenähtes wo zusätzlich tragen
möchte dann gerne aber es darf nicht zu
einer konkurrenz kommen zwischen
medizinischen einrichtungen und sehr
löblich einen sehr wertvollen schutz von
menschen im lebensmittelhandel ganz
wichtig aber da haben wir ja auch schon
unter nicht verbauen wir sind bei der
klassischen frage es muss auch der
kanzleramtsminister beantworten woher
nehmen und nicht stehlen
markus söder sagte gestern wir brauchen
milliarden schutzmasken und er lässt sie
von der polizei bewacht
wann werden wir endlich genug
medizinische masken haben und was sagen
sie auch mediziner zu der frage der
selbst genähten mund schütze also ich
glaube dazu was ich schon alles gesagt
auch dass sie sind eine gute ergänzung
aber man muss sehr deutlich machen sie
schützen weder den träger wirklich von
einer infektion noch umgedreht
die menschen um einen herum und insofern
darf in keiner weise zu irgendeiner
reduzierung der vorsicht bei den
abstandsregeln oder anderen
hygienemaßnahmen führen
und in der tat ich finde das sehr gut
pflegeheime die menschen die dort
arbeiten mit hochwertigen medizinischen
massen auszustatten
das ist gerade unser größtes problem
wenn der korona virus einmal unserem
alten pflegeheim ist dann führt das zu
ganz vielen infektionen
das ist für die menschen hochgefährlich
und das findet auch unglaublich kräfte
im gesundheitswesen
das ist für alle eigentlich eine
katastrophe und deshalb solange die
situation so ist wie er aber
unter hochdruck daran nicht nur im
ausland masken und andere schutzkleidung
zu kaufen sondern wir sind auch aktiv
mit vielen vielen deutschen unternehmen
im gespräch
das ist ja auch in deutschland jetzt
wieder eine produktion aufbauen sehr
schnell möglichst viel aber natürlich
auch langfristig das ist aus heutiger
sicht ein fehler dass wir eine solche
produktion nicht im inland oder
zumindest in europa im großen stil haben
und das leben ist auch dass jetzt wieder
einer dieser punkte
wo ich auch jeden tag da sitze und frage
wann kommt denn mehr weil das natürlich
jetzt auch ein zeitkritisches problem
ist das ist ganz klar
und die frage auch noch mal nach aachen
hat simons wie sie sagen ihre größte
sorge völlig zu recht sind die alten und
seniorenheimen jetzt natürlich wie gut
ist da die ausstattung mal unabhängig
davon dass man den papa und die mama
nicht besuchen darf wie gut ist die
ausstattung und der schutz der menschen
die da leben also die ausstattung mit
persönlicher schutzausrüstung ist auch
da natürlich ein problem
und wenn wir als als krisenstäbe da
nicht eben mit der versorgung helfen
dann ist das kaum zu leisten für die
einzelnen einrichtungen einen
entsprechenden medizinischen schutz zu
bekommen
wir haben zusätzliche maßnahmen eben
auch in den einrichtungen wir machen
mittlerweile auch ryan abstriche sobald
anheim betroffen ist testen wir dort
alle bewohner aller mitarbeitenden um
dort eben auch nur größtmögliche
sicherheit herzustellen wir haben die
krankenhäuser verpflichtet niemanden zu
entlassen ohne ein testergebnis damit
ein heim eben auch weiß worauf er sich
einlässt klar und natürlich gelten bei
uns auch schon lange besucher stocks
jetzt haben wir frau wurden auch in
unserem eingangs gezeigten beitrag schon
über diese umkehr isolation gesprochen
also die idee dass man tatsächlich nach
und nach menschen wieder in das normale
leben geht und diese risikogruppen im
grunde isoliert
das ist einleuchtend aber es ist
wahnsinnig hart es ist hart und ich
glaube es ist auch etwas verengen
ich glaube man muss mehrere
differenzierungen einführen das eine
sind natürlich die hochrisikogruppen das
sind aber auch nicht nur die alten
menschen sondern das sind ja solche mit
vorerkrankungen die dann zu schweren
verläufen neigen und die ziehen sich
durch alle altersklassen und im übrigen
sind auch schon ausreichend vorher
gesunde menschen ohne vorerkrankungen an
dieser ecke ankurbelt 19 gestorben also
man darf sich da auch nicht der illusion
hingeben als sei man als junger gesunder
mensch und so völlig außerhalb des
risiko bereiches der man kann aber auch
zum beispiel nach regionen unterscheiden
man kann da sehen wir sind die
infektionszahlen wie sind die
bedingungen dineen die infrastruktur die
verhaltensweisen der menschen
und dann macht man vielleicht in
mecklenburg vorpommern andere bereiche
schon viel eher auf als in nordrhein
westfalen oder bayern
das anders man kann nach
wirtschaftlichen und auch
gesellschaftlichen sektoren
unterscheiden
ja also da wo arbeitsbedingungen sind wo
die menschen ausreichend abstand haben
wo die sicherheitsmaßnahmen und die
hygienevorschriften einzuhalten sind die
kann man viel schneller wieder eröffnet
als diejenigen wo man ganz eng
zusammenhängt und man diese
sicherheitsabstände zum beispiel gar
nicht so halten kann und diese
differenzierungen deswegen brauchen wir
auch diese zeit um darüber gut
nachzudenken auch daten zu sammeln diese
differenzierungen müssen wir einführen
und ergibt sich eigentlich einen
kriterienkatalog letztlich sind es vier
kriterien unter die man das subsumieren
kann wo man dann eine schöne
schrittweise strategie entwickeln kann
und dann sind wir wieder bei helge braun
verbrauchen sie haben von denen umkehr
isolationen auch schon gesprochen
in einem spiegel interview was würde das
bedeuten wenn wir tatsächlich einzelne
regionen einzelne branchen oder eben
auch eben eine bestimmte zahl von
menschen unterschiedlich mit verboten
ausstatten
also um verbote geht es glaube ich nicht
sondern wir sehen ja auch jetzt wo wir
eigentlich schon sehr sehr weite
beruhigung des öffentlichen lebens haben
auch jetzt passiert es dass in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen plötzlich
corona ausbrüche passieren das heißt wir
müssen eigentlich schon die ganze zeit
und jetzt erst recht
uns enorm darin einüben dass wir eben
die schutzbedürftigen gruppen schützen
und dabei geht es nicht um
nein es geht aus meiner sicht eben nicht
um soziale isolation und das geht auch
nicht um eine strafe sondern es geht
darum diese menschen zu schützen weil
sie einer besonderen gefahr ausgesetzt
sind wenn in unserem land jetzt durch
die steigerung der zahlen immer mehr
infizierte sind die ihnen potenziell
erheblich schaden können und deshalb
geht es eben genau darum durch
nachbarschaftshilfe durch kontakte durch
aktivitäten dafür zu sorgen dass es eben
nicht zur sozialen isolation kommt so
muss die leute sozusagen an dem an dem
leben soweit teilhaben können
das ist diese haben sie ganz besonders
gelten und dass da wo sie sind ganz
besondere gene vorschriften eingehalten
werden ganz entscheiden dass man
trotzdem eben in einzelnen bereichen
über diese differenzierungen nachdenkt
manche länder sind weniger betroffen
einzelne regionen sind weniger betroffen
einzelnen branchen sind weniger
betroffen halten sie das für richtig
also differenziert draufschauen ist
immer gut und wir haben natürlich auch
jetzt schon in deutschland völlig
unterschiedliche situationen also nun
über sachsen anhalt oder heinsberg redet
und deshalb ist natürlich auch eine
differenzierte betrachtungsweise richtig
ist ein aspekt noch wichtig bei allen
schutz also und wirklich sehr
gerechtfertigten schutz bedürfnissen und
auch dem willen den schutz zu gewähren
die menschen sind schon dann auch noch
selbstbestimmt dahingehend welche
risiken sie in kauf nehmen möchte und
gerade bei den alten menschen und ich
spreche jetzt nicht von den schwer
dementen menschen aber den alten
menschen denen ihr ganzes leben
wegbricht und lebt ein alter mensch
alleine zu hause das einzige wasserratte
war irgendwie am tag x seine frau seien
man im pflegeheim zu besuchen oder ins
café zu gehen
all das ist jetzt weg und würde aber
eigentlich das risiko eingehen weil er
sagt ja wenn ich mich jetzt infiziere
und wendig das risiko eingehe zu sterben
dann ist das mein risiko und das möchte
ich eingehen
das müssen wir schon auch in die
waagschale werfen wir können jetzt nicht
einfach sagen müssen die alle beschützen
sondern wir müssen schon auch mit denen
sprechen wie viel selbstbestimmung sie
dann noch ausüben möchten natürlich sind
das dann auch wieder mögliche weitere
ansteckende mensch noch das müssen wir
im blick haben
aber die selbstbestimmung darf jetzt
nicht da ganz außer kraft gesetzt werden
noch ein wichtiger hinweis frau bringt
man die größte hoffnung liegen jetzt auf
medizinische heilung entweder den
impfstoffen oder den medikamenten
wo würden sie sagen liegt ihre größte
hoffnung schon wieder die vor gedanke
hoffnung
die hoffnung ist auch wichtig meine
größte hoffnung liegt in der impfung
ganz klar das einschränkende dabei ist
die impfung wird einfach noch zeit
brauchen und sie wird uns jetzt in
dieser situation nicht helfen das ist es
ist leider so ich verstehe diesen wunsch
und alle fragen danach aber wir müssen
einfach auch sicher sein einmal dass sie
wirkt wird einmal dass sie sicher ist
dass wir keine nebenwirkungen haben und
da gibt es auch beispiele dass das im
jahr das studien dann auch zu zu
todesopfern geführt haben und das ist
das ist riesig an erst abzuziehen und
dieses risiko möchte man nicht eingehen
muss man ganz klar die risiken und denkt
ja das ganz klar ab weg und nun ist ja
aber interessant was sich tut in der
welt weil nennen sie werden wenigstens
50 forscherteams exakt daran arbeiten
weil sie sich auch den durchbruch in
exakt dieser front erhoffen
nun kennen die grippe-impfungen die sind
mal mehr und mal weniger gut wo hat man
denn erfolgreich gegen viren gekämpft
da gibt es viele beispiele es gibt wären
wir haben die pocken besiegt und es gibt
viele beispiele es gibt auch ja die
masern haben wir noch nicht ganz unter
kontrolle und auch andere
infektionskrankheiten nicht aber die
impfung ist ist für meine für mein
empfinden der heilige gral den wir hier
erreichen müssen um das leben wieder
ganz normal weiterführen zu können
und es gibt wahnsinnig viele ansätze wie
sie gerade sagten es gibt
50 die sich mittlerweile die die whu
registriert hat und ich bin total
hoffnungsvoll dass einer davon
funktionieren wird
aber es gibt auch viele ansätze wo man
noch überhaupt nicht abschätzen kann
werden die zum erfolg führen oder nicht
und das ist so ein bisschen das risiko
dabei und das ist nicht nur ein bisschen
risiko von diesen 50 wird bei 2 nämlich
in den usa und in china auch schon an
menschen getestet wie sind es alles
freiwillige also das kann ich für china
jetzt nicht beurteilen ich weiß dass es
in amerika getestet wird es ist ein rna
impfstoff und da gibt es auch viele
berichte zu und das sind tatsächlich
freiwilliger und das ist auch eine
impfstoff methode die ja die ist ganz
neu es gibt noch keinen impfstoff der
auf dieser basis entwickelt wurde und
für den gezeigt wurde erst wirksam und
er ist sicher aber man verspricht sich
sehr viel davon und man wird jetzt sehen
wie die ersten studien verlaufen aber
das kann man auch erst in ein paar
monaten wirklich sagen dann haben wir
gestern der presse entnommen dass die
bundesregierung in größenordnung dieses
papier angeschafft hat also in japan
zugelassen als avi garnen das ist auch
ein büro statik um was an lungen fieber
bekämpfen soll
ist das gut angelegtes geld glauben sie
also ich glaube in der situation in der
wir sind sollte man viele optionen
verfolgen und es gibt sehr viele
wirkstoffe die diskutiert werden und die
auch schnäppchen energischen erprobung
sind es ist noch zu früh
wirklich zu sagen das ist jetzt der
vielversprechenden wirkstoff das rem
diese wir sieht sehr erfolgsversprechend
aus das ist dieses ebola medica genau
der wurde ursprünglich für etwas anderes
entwickelt für ebola und dass sie
tatsächlich sehr gut aus und da muss man
jetzt noch ein bisschen abwarten wie
sich das wie ob sich das erhärtet es
reicht nicht sich auf eine studie zu
verlassen ist es besser wenn
verschiedene studien das gleiche zeigen
muss man es ja ganz wichtig und was kann
man ethisch verantwortbare tun um die
impfstoffentwicklung zu beschleunigen
herr braun das haben sie gefragt und
wahrscheinlich ist es wieder die politik
die diese frage beantworten
also wir haben ja sehr klare regeln in
deutschland als zu einem sicheren
impfstoff entwicklung gehört und jetzt
stellt sich natürlich die ethische frage
wenn wir einen impfstoff früher haben
dann kann der angesichts einer solchen
pandemie natürlich auch leben retten und
deshalb sozusagen muss politik auch die
frage an wissenschaft an ethik stellen
gibt es dinge die zum beispiel dass wir
in einer phase 3 studie schon mehr
patienten einschließen ist dass in einer
solchen situation ethisch vertretbar
oder nicht und grundsätzlich muss man
aber sagen dass wir dadurch jetzt eine
erhebliche beschleunigung der
impfstoffentwicklung gekommen das glaube
ich nicht sondern erkenntnisgewinn lässt
sich eben nicht beliebig beschleunigen
aber diese frage müssen wir jetzt auch
einmal besprechen weil wir haben ja auch
zwei impfstoffkandidaten in deutschland
klappt und unser zuständig ist institut
das paul ehrlich institut arbeitet mit
beiden sehr eng zusammen dass nicht auch
noch irgendwelche zulassungs oder
verwaltungsprozesse die impfstoffe in
technischen behindern aber die frage ist
eben können wir auch medizinisch
vertretbar noch was tun damit wir
möglichst schnell an einen impfstoff
kommen aber natürlich die probanden
sicherheit ist ein ros guten da machen
wir auch keine abstriche auch eine
wichtige frage frau wirken da muss im
grunde sicherheit abgewogen werden gegen
geschwindigkeit auch das ist wieder eine
echte zwickmühle weil nicht grundlos
sind unsere regularien und unsere
zulassungsbestimmungen sehr steigt
wir haben über jahre jahrzehnte
gewachsene forschungs ethische standards
die sind ja auch ins gesetz geschrieben
bei arzneimittelgesetz beispielsweise
und wir haben ethikkommission die die
studien bewerten und beraten etc also
dass da gibt es viele voraussetzungen
gleichwohl glaube ich dass auch
besondere umstände hier besondere
maßnahmen zeitigen können die
also die zulassungsbehörde den usa
beispielsweise hat auch die möglichkeit
von sondergenehmigungen und
sonderanwendungen und wir könnten
beispielsweise hier natürlich alles
abgesichert über ethik kommission die
ezb schon in die abwägung gehen ob zur
abwägung eines hohen risiko groß auch
höhere risiken in kauf genommen werden
können natürlich auf freiwilliger basis
natürlich unter den kind
wissenschaftlichen standard die dann
letztlich zu einer evidenzbasierten
medizin führen
aber wenn ein mensch ein hohes risiko
hat schwer zu erkranken wird er auch ein
höheres risiko in kauf nehmen
dieses risiko nicht erleiden zu müssen
dadurch dass er oder die manifestation
nicht allein zu müssen dadurch dass er
diesen impfstoff bekommen auch eine
schwierige entscheidung hat simons wenn
wir uns eben genau für diese situation
stellt oder uns vergegenwärtigen dass es
schon vorbehalte seien auch gegen masern
impfungen grippe impfungen gibt glauben
sie dass die menschen sich überzeugt
einen völlig neuen impfstoff geben
lassen würden ich glaube dass die ganze
situation sehr viel auch damit zu tun
hat wie sehr gelingt es sonst die
bevölkerung mitzunehmen weil wir erleben
im moment dass ganz viel damit
zusammenhängt wie gut wir aufklären wie
gut wir informieren wie transparent wie
auch sind wie ehrlich wir mit den leuten
umgehen das geht damit los dass wir in
den heimen informieren dass wir die
heime unterstützen das hat aber auch
damit zu tun wie wir die bevölkerung
aufklären wie wir unternehmen aufklären
was passiert wenn in der in der
belegschaft plötzlich ein positiver fall
auftaucht und so weiter und genau so
wird es auch sein wenn ein impfstoff
auftritt man wird diesem impfstoff in
dem maße vertrauen wie wir transparenz
herstellen über die art und weise was
gerückt dieser impfstoff klar dass
werden wie rogan dazu sagen verbringt
man wann werden wir wohl ogen sagen ich
stelle mich freiwillig zur verfügung
weil sie die impfung für eine impfung
auch dass ich dann musste ich mich erst
mal beraten mit meinen impfstoff
experten kollegen und wenn die mir sagen
macht dass religion das risiko für dich
hält sich stark in grenzen würde ich
mich da glatt freiwillig hinsetzen ja
das würde ich machen und ich glaube die
bereitschaft
wer auch da ich bin aber gar nicht
sicher ob wir das in der älteren
bevölkerung unbedingt versuchen sollten
sondern eher die jüngere bevölkerung
ansprechen die dann die gesund sind und
natürlich auch klar sie auswählen haben
sie vorerkrankungen oder nicht wir
sollten gesunde personen wählen und
klappt die zum mitmachen bewegen
das wäre gut und wir reden von
frühestens herbst oder sagen sie das
wird noch länger da
ich fürchte das wird noch ein bisschen
länger dauern dann müssen wir auf diese
medizinische heilung die natürlich die
beste lösung wäre offensichtlich noch
ein bisschen warten und bis dahin
versuchen wir weiter das virus in schach
zu halten und was uns dabei hilft und
helfen kann und muss sind daten und auch
die sind noch nicht so wahnsinnig
präzise es gibt eine berufsgruppe die
nennen sich die mode lehre und die
versuchen antworten auf die frage zu
finden wie sehr sich diese solche schon
ausgebreitet hat und was einzelne
maßnahmen tatsächlich bewirkt haben und
ich freue mich dass wir heute einen
echten mode lehrer bei und sagen
professor dirk brockmann nämlich hier
von der humboldt universität in berlin
ein professor brockmann ich stehe in dem
hin eigentlichen abstand alles ist okay
wie viele menschen sind infiziert und
wie viele sind schon wieder gesund wir
haben keine antwort auf die frage also
generell muss man dazusagen dass die
modelle die wir so entwickeln aber auch
kollegen im ausland sich damit
beschäftigen wie die dynamik sich
fortpflanzt also jetzt zum beispiel auf
deutschland gesehen aber auch in anderen
europäischen ländern
und was wir können ist die den verlauf
der gemälde zahlen zum beispiel zu
verstehen dass immer die erste frage die
modellversuch zu beantworten können wir
die verläufe verstehen wo man dann in
der prognostik oder in der vorhersage
geht und dazu braucht man aber immer das
ist für die modellierer sehr wichtig da
die zahl der infizierten werden und an
der arbeiten wir noch die wie sie diese
prognosen genau errechnen wenn die basis
eigentlich noch so wacklig ist können
sie das beschreiben kann man das
verstehen als normalsterblicher ich
glaube das kann man ganz gut verstehen
also es ist eine ein aspekt dass man
sich an einem tag die zahlen anschaut
das ist ein statisches bild aber
praktisch alle modelle mathematische
modelle die dann so in den computer rein
gefüttert werden beschäftigen sich mit
der dynamik und wenn man sich die
kurvenverläufe anschaut dann sieht man
wenn man erfahrung damit hat strukturen
in diesen kurven und aus diesen
strukturen kann man wieder rückschlüsse
ableiten und dabei ist es nicht so
wichtig erstaunlicherweise dass man
wirklich die absolut richtigen zahlen
hat inklusive dunkelziffer sondern man
braucht eine richtige stichprobe und
dann muss man natürlich vergleich wie
sieht das in deutschland auch in
frankreich in spanien in singapur in
china und da sieht man dann
ähnlichkeiten in diesen mustern und das
daraus kann man dann rückschlüsse
ableiten also was professor strikt jetzt
unbedingt in heinsberg macht ist absolut
richtig nämlich die heinsberger
bevölkerung repräsentativ 1000 menschen
zu befragen also immer repräsentative
zahlen sind gut das ist immer wichtig
die modelle
ja das ist also alle ansätze die
repräsentative zahlen den modellieren
liefern sind wichtig aber nochmal wir
brauchen halt zahlen über einen
zeitverlauf und dann kann man halt
überlegen was steckt dahinter wie gut
sind maßnahmen so und genau dahin kommen
wir jetzt natürlich es sind viel mehr
infizierte als krank es gibt viel mehr
menschen die infiziert sind aber keine
symptome haben ungefähr 40 prozent
wie kann man also ausrechnen wie hoch
eigentlich die dunkelziffer ist also ich
komme aus der physik und in der physik
gibt es dunkle materie im weltall und
das blöde bei der dunklen materie ist
man sieht sie nicht
und deshalb heißt ja auch so und so
ähnlich ist das mit der dunkelziffer die
heißt dunkelziffer weil sie halt im
dunkeln ist und bestenfalls kann man sie
indirekt messen und da gibt es
verschiedene ideen dahinter zu kommen
aber es ist natürlich ganz wichtig dass
man eine stichprobe hat für irgendwelche
prognosen vorhersagen
sie haben klassisch beschrieben dass sie
mit telefon daten arbeiten die sind
randomisiert sie sind anonymisiert und
deshalb auch okay also auch akzeptiert
und konnten daraus lesen wie sich reise
und einschränkungen der bewegung von
menschen
bewirkt haben was haben sie genau
gelesen also wir hatten zunächst in den
fallzahl kurven gemerkt dass irgendetwas
abweicht von dem was man typischerweise
erwarten würde nämlich dieses freie
exponentielle wachstum von dem immer die
rede ist und in dem sich in gleichen
abständen die zahlen immer verdoppeln
wenn man sich das genau anschaut in
deutschland aber auch in anderen ländern
gibt es da eine abweichung dh das ist
ein indikator darauf dafür dass die
gesellschaft reagiert sich anders
verhält und das konnten wir dann
überprüfen indem wir diese mobilität
flüsse untersucht haben die sind wie sie
sagten aggregiert das heißt das sind nur
flüsse von bewegung und da die decken
sich genau mit dem was wir aus den
fallzahlen lesen also zum beispiel hat
sich die mobilität in deutschland in den
letzten drei märzwochen um etwa 45
prozent verringert mehr in den
großstädten und das kann man dann wieder
mit den modellen abgleichen um das deckt
sich mit dem ok können sie denn sehen
und das ist genau die frage die sie
schon an notiert haben können sie den
sehen was bisherige maßnahmen bereits
gebracht haben
über die bewegung hinaus muss die
modelle also nicht nur unsere sondern
auch die von kollegen die beinhalten
diesen effekt dass die gesellschaft ihr
verhalten ändert als antwort auf die
pandemie effektiv das heißt diese
modelle können nicht genau beantworten
welche maßnahme jetzt welchen einfluss
hat das kann man erst dann später damit
vergleichen
dass es so zu sagen man sieht nur diesen
gesamteffekt und der verhaltensänderung
und wie ist der gesamteffekt jetzt kann
man sagen dass wir aus einem wachstum
der langsam auf ein plateau gekommen
sind oder ist es noch ein sehr kleines
plateau also für alle auch für die große
mehrzahl der länder wo wir über viele
wochen das beobachten sieht man jetzt
einfach in den empirischen daten das
sozusagen nach seinem berganstieg jetzt
so eine platte kommt das sieht man in
italien in spanien in deutschland in
vielen anderen ländern auch und wie das
eben so ist bei einem plateau dann ist
die hoffnung groß dass das dann berg
runter geht aber genau so wie das auch
beim bergsteigen ist weiß man nicht was
wie die zukunft ist das ist halt gerade
in so einem plateau gebiet und dann muss
man daran arbeiten dass es wieder runter
geht die modelle können das aber noch
nicht vorhersagen
also wir haben eigentlich eine ziemlich
schreckliche datenbasis wir wissen nicht
wie viele menschen infiziert sind wir
wissen nicht präzise wie viele gesund
sind wir kennen vielleicht hochgerechnet
die zahl derjenigen die krank und
infiziert sind was würde ihnen an
technik herr brockmann helfen um besser
voraussagen zu können was etwas bewirkt
hilfe helfen da also sie kennen die
diskussion kann da diese app
beispielsweise helfen der bewegung sap
und eine identifikation sap oder würden
sie sagen wir müssen viel mehr testen
also alles ist gut alles was daten
liefert ist gut um modelle
hochauflösender zu machen unsere modelle
funktionieren jetzt auf der ebene von
nation das heißt wir haben fallzahlen in
verschiedenen ländern und können aus
diesen kurven etwas lesen wenn wir aber
hoch auflösende arbeiten wollen zb
fragen für spezielle landkreise zu
beantworten dann braucht man viel viel
mehr und viel bessere daten sonst werden
die modelle halte schlecht auf diesem
niveau und dazu ist es notwendig zum
beispiel eine app zu haben ist es wird
ja immer von der app gesprochen
es gibt eine app die zum beispiel das
contact racing macht dass man
infektionsketten rekonstruieren kann
natürlich in anonymisierter form aber
auch andere apps wie zb die dunkelziffer
viel besser schätzen können als das was
wir jetzt haben und zu genau den ländern
die das schon erprobt haben und zwar
erfolgreich erprobt haben kommen wir
jetzt ich danke erst mal ganz herzlich
an dieser stelle
der wird von südkorea gesprochen es wird
von singapur gesprochen
es wird von china natürlich auch
gesprochen aber auch von taiwan
diese länder gelten das haben sie längst
irgendwie schon gehört decken gelten als
sein großes vorbild weil sie vermieden
haben dass es einen london gegeben hat
in ihren ländern
der preis dafür war dass man tatsächlich
hart auch private daten der betroffenen
ermittelt hat und nun entwickelt auch
deutschland eine solche app oder besser
gesagt die architektur
für eine app noch nicht vor zwei wochen
sagte der kanzleramtschef erst einmal
gelten die einschränkungen des
öffentlichen lebens bis zum zwanzigsten
april die frage wie es dann weitergeht
kann man frühestens in zehn bis 14 tagen
beurteilen
heute ist 30 beitrag ich versuche mir
sofort dann sehen sie liebe zuschauer
dass das tatsächlich alles wild halb ist
ich versuche jetzt mal die richtige maß
abzufahren es ist die zum handy tracking
hier sind ihre zukunft aus das handy als
waffe gegen das virus
alarm bei infizierten kontakt diese
debatte muss geführt werden um eine
positionierung dazu ist glaube ich
deutlich geworden ich weiß aber
gleichzeitig auch dass es nur geht wenn
es einen breiten gesellschaftlichen
rückhalt hat mit einer app und
aktivierter bluetooth-funktion willmann
infektionsketten verfolgen und kappen
kommen sich menschen näher erkennen sich
die handys und tauschen anonyme
identifikationsnummern aus wird dann ein
nutzer positiv auf 19 getestet löst das
einen alarm aus aller app-nutzer die zum
beispiel länger als 15 minuten kontakt
mit der infizierten personen hatten
werden über handy gewarnt sie werden
aufgefordert zu hause zu bleiben und
sich untersuchen zu lassen
die daten werden nach zwei bis drei
wochen gelöscht
man muss die bürger und bürger davon
überzeugen dass sie bestimmte daten zum
nutzen aller miteinander teilen hat
siemens ihre leute müssen noch heftig
herumtelefonieren hätten sie so eine app
auch gerne also im moment gelingt uns
das sehr gut mit dem ruhm telefonieren
wir haben 140 menschen die nichts
anderes tun jeden tag als
herumtelefonieren insofern bin ich sehr
zufrieden mit dem wie das klappt und wir
erleben auch dass die menschen sehr
verantwortungsbewusst umgehen mit der
angabe ihrer kontaktpersonen was wir
auch erleben ist allerdings dass in dem
moment wo das gesundheitsamt anruft und
sagt also wir haben sie hier auf einer
liste sie sind möglicherweise von anti
personen das dann sehr viel angst
entsteht werden einen fall da hat eine
mutter ihre kinder sofort von einem
kindergeburtstag abgeholt und auf der
vater ein unfall gebaut
gut dass da nichts passiert ist der wäre
möglicherweise schlimmer ausgegangen
sonst als eben eine infektion
ich mag mir nicht vorstellen wie das ist
wenn das handy plötzlich auf klopft und
da kommt eine sms die mir das sagt was
das für ängste auslöst ist glaube ich
jedem verständlich und mir ist natürlich
auch wichtig dass die leute nicht
behandelt werden das hätten sie aus satz
wer kontaktperson geworden ist oder wer
infiziert ist der hat ja nichts falsch
gemacht automatisch der ist opfer einer
krankheit geworden und muss auch so
behandelt werden und nicht wie jemand
der eben jetzt plötzlich aussätziger
geworden ist also da müssen wir sehr
vorsichtig seien sehr sensibel mit
umgehen und da wird es auch nötig sein
neben der simplen sms sie sind jetzt
hier lange in kontakt gewesen mit
jemandem sofort sehr schnell kontakt
herzustellen wenn er nicht umgehend
jemand hinterher anruft dann entsteht
sehr viel angst sehr viel unsicherheit
und dies auch nicht gut wir machen die
runde was sagt die biologin was würde
aus medizinischer sicht es bringen frau
bringt man wenn es diese app überprüfung
gibt und zwar freiwillig und die daten
werden nach drei wochen gelöscht das ist
jetzt das was die politik nicht nur
diskutiert sondern bald machen möchte es
ist sinnvoll menschen so früh wie es
geht zu warnen und sie
zu isolieren das ist ganz klar und wie
das mit der kommunikation dann genau
läuft das werden wir bestimmt noch
erfahren so weiß ich jetzt auch also
interessant ist wenigstens das wissen
wir von der bundeskanzlerin herr braun
sie würde sich sofort so eine app
herunterladen zweifel ich logischerweise
die kanzlerin wäre dabei wie viele
menschen müssten das machen damit sich
wirklich invaliden wert hat sich
produzent treu natürlich mehr als die
hälfte wären jeden fall schon mal ein
sehr guter wert und die diskussion
finger so an dass wir wirklich nach
china geguckt haben haben uns gefragt
ist das ein vorbild und in china wird
wirklich das bewegungsprofil der
bürgerinnen und bürger zentral
gespeichert und wir haben jetzt eine
expertengruppe zusammengesetzten etwas
tolles geschafft das eigentlich wirklich
nur wenn sich zwei menschen 15 minuten
also epidemiologisch bedeutsamen sehr
nah gewesen sind über bluetooth wird die
entfernung gemessen dann übermittelt nur
so eine art nummernschild an das handy
des anderen nicht mal meinen namen und
das gilt dann auch zum beispiel für den
anonymen kontakt in der bahn neben mir
den ich bei einer späteren kontakt
befragung nie benennen könnte und so
erhoffen wir uns dass wenn viele
menschen diese app freiwillig einsetzen
wir die kontakte vollständiger
identifizieren und dass es schneller
geht als über befragung und trotzdem ist
richtig das ergebnis ist dann dass man
informiert wird dass man zu einem
infizierten kontakt hatte und das dann
aber der weg ist der anruf beim
gesundheitsamt deshalb bauen wir gerade
viel personal aus und dass man dann
professionell beraten wird was muss ich
jetzt tun in quarantäne gehen ab wann
ist der test sinnvoll das sind alles
dinge da setzen wir weiter auf den
persönlichen kontakt aber erstmal die
schnelle information da ist aber auch
die digitale unterstützung ein ganz ganz
große hilfe
okay was sagt da die ethikerin dazu also
um die freiheit aller nicht
einzuschränken schränken wir dann die
freiheit weniger ein
dazu muss man verschiedene apps
unterscheiden und ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig jetzt in der kommunikation
in der öffentlichkeit es gibt die spd
also die die ortsdaten verwendet
das tut diese ppt nicht die hat nur
diese bluetooth-verbindung dass die
frage ob man die person identifizieren
kann tatsächlich das tut dieser andere
app eben auch nicht dann ruft auch nicht
das gesundheitsamt den betreffenden an
sondern der betreffende der diese
nachricht bekommt ruft das
gesundheitsamt an also das ist ja auch
noch mal ein unterschied der europäische
ethikrat hat heute heute mittag eine
stellungnahme kurz stellungnahme zur pid
19 pandemie herausgegeben wo er diese
technologischen lösungen auch
befürwortet denn sie sind ja in der tat
im vergleich zu anderen dingen zum teil
eine freiheits ermöglichung auch wenn
sie manchmal noch mit bestimmten
einschränkungen einhergehen können
nutzer per pc apps sehe ich die weniger
die daten ethikkommission hier die
deutsche die die bundesregierung beraten
hat hat ja auch einen solchen asics by
design ansatz verfolgt wenn es also
anonym bleibt freiwillig runter geladen
wird der staat nicht involviert wird etc
dann sind das ja alles bedingungen die
dem schutz der grundrechte nur zugute
kommen und dient dann machen wir hier
vielleicht ein punkt und sagen die
nächste große hoffnung frau bringt man
ach so herr simons eines daher möchte
ich dann noch sagen wenn das
gesundheitsamt angerufen wird dann muss
da auch ganz schnell jemand dran gehen
können ja also wir haben drei call
center aufgebaut wir haben viele hundert
mitarbeiter zusammengezogen aus
unterschiedlichen bereichen der
verwaltung die einen tollen job machen
und trotzdem gibt es immer wieder bürger
die nicht durchkommen weil dann die
telefonleitungen überlaufen sind und so
stellen sie sich eine karnevalsfeier vor
bei der nach der karnevalsfeier bei 100
200 300 leuten auf dem handy auf blockt
achtung sie sind jetzt hier
identifiziert worden
die rufen alle an das ist gut aber dann
muss der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
in die lage versetzt werden und
unterstützt werden um dann auch hier
gehen zu können und wir wollen dass wir
tun das auch sehr gründlich und mit viel
personal einsatz
aber es ist wiederum eine
herausforderung ich zitiere sie und da
reden wir über unsere mängel
wir haben verbringt man nächstes super
wichtiges thema auch beim testen mengen
wir würden von
dem testen wenn es denn großflächiger
geschehen könnte natürlich wahnsinnig
hier erfahren
aber der verband der laborarzt sagt es
ist illusorisch vielmehr zu testen warum
sagt der verband der labor ärzte das was
fehlt fehlen die reagenz jeden fehlt
diese pipetten fehlt personal also das
personal ist ein problem ja da gibt es
mittlerweile aber auch initiativen das
personal aus anderen bereichen das aber
erfahren ist in den techniken aus hilft
das ist bei uns da komme ich in
braunschweig und hannover sehr gut mit
geräte sind eher kein problem es gibt
auch sehr innovative lösung dass man
sich mit den blutbanken zusammentut und
dass man mittlerweile auch die kapazität
erhöhen kann indem man proben zusammen
bringen dass ich jetzt nicht jede
einzelne probe teste sondern sie pulver
machen genau und dass sich dadurch die
test kapazität natürlich auch sehr stark
erhöhen gehören
das heißt wir schaffen diese 500.000 pro
woche und müssten das aber eigentlich
auch noch ausweiten
sie müsste ausgeweitet werden ja wir
sind die bestrebungen da das problem
sind schon immer noch die lieferketten
verschiedene reagenzien es gibt aber
auch da viele entwicklungen das neue
tests entwickelt werden und auch
schnellere test sie schneller zur
verfügung stehen also da gibt es
unheimlich viel in bewegung so putin
wie ist das noch bei ihnen in der region
also wir haben die tests noch nicht für
alle und auch erst recht nicht für alle
die anrufen bei ihnen wonach wählen sie
aus wenn sie testen auch das ist ja ein
wir halten uns ganz eng an den kriterien
des lkw fest wir schaffen das auch immer
nach wenn sich was verändert wir haben
eine hotline bei der man anrufen kann
und dann wird eben abgefragt nach dem
fluss schema des rk ii wir haben noch
mal besonders auch unterstützen den
mitarbeitern gesagt zur verdeutlichung
des rk isaca mitarbeiter in der pflege
können auch erleichtern einen test
kommen dass das natürlich auch zutrifft
für menschen in der altenpflege in den
wohneinrichtungen in den
pflegeeinrichtungen für menschen mit
behinderungen
ja und dann haben wir zwei abstrich
zentren und zwei mobile teams die in die
alten und pflegeheime
waren sodass wir mittlerweile zwischen
12 und 14 100 tests am tag machen können
was natürlich da noch bedeutet sie
müssen plus die tester in den
krankenhäusern gemacht werden und in den
haushalts praxen sie müssen dann auch
ein team haben das nachher 1000 bis 1500
testergebnisse sortiert auswertet die
leute anspricht und so weiter und so
weiter
wir brauchen wir sind wieder bei den
klassischen fragen testen wir noch zu
unsystematisch
also wir haben gerade jetzt am anfang
eine ganz hohe zahl von negativen tests
gemacht das war ein hinweis darauf dass
wir wahrscheinlich noch zu unspezifisch
sind aber ich glaube das hat sich jetzt
mittlerweile ganz gut ergeben und
möglicherweise in der tat auch die app
über die wir gerade diskutiert haben
auch noch mal so ein punkt um das zu
objektivieren weil momentan ist es ja
schon noch so dass ich sagen kann
vielleicht bin ich auch von jemandem
hatte ich mit jemandem kontakt den ich
nicht kenne der sehr anonym ist also
wenn ich jetzt symptome habe habe ich
zumindest subjektiv das gefühl ich würde
mich gerne testen lassen auch sozusagen
von den erker empfehlungen umkehren gar
nicht gedeckt ist und wenn ich dann aber
sozusagen viele menschen so ein system
verwenden
dann kann das auch noch mal helfen die
die die test kapazität zu steuern
aber wir wollen sie auch ausweiten was
ist nicht nur so dass wir uns und sie
haben sie nicht mehr aus natürlich auch
maschinen sogar sie kaufen auch
maschinen damit wir eben nicht weiter in
dieser ohnmacht sind bestimmte dinge
offensichtlich momentan nicht mal mit
geld bezahlen zu können
da haben wir jetzt der stelle kein
problem das ist alles bezieht und das
kaufen wir auch ein
aber generell ist das glaube ich jetzt
ein verteilungsproblem
wir müssen nicht nur die kranken testen
sondern wir müssen natürlich noch viel
mehr die infizierten testen und nicht
jeder nochmal der keine symptome hat ist
automatisch gesund sondern er ist
vielleicht ein infizierter wir wissen
auch diese zahl nicht wie viele
infizierte wir haben ja da sozusagen bei
welchen die möglicherweise ohne es zu
merken
eine infektion durchgemacht haben ist
natürlich nicht der rachen test
sozusagen das aktive virus sucht der
richtige sondern da brauchen wir ein
antikörpertest ins blut und den gibt es
auch schon aber der ist noch nicht so
genau wie wir ihn brauchen
er kann den fatalen fehler machen dass
er einem suggeriert man sei schon immun
bestimmt am ende gar nicht wenn der test
jetzt wirklich etwas besser ist dann
wollen wir glaube ich was auch dann den
modellieren gut gefällt eine große serie
von menschen die glauben sie hätten nie
was mitbewohner zu tun gehabt freiwillig
testen um zu gucken wie hoch ist die
dunkelziffer wie viele haben sich
einfach so genannte still gefeiert also
die haben corona durchgemacht und waren
die glückspilze die ist nicht mal
gemerkt hat wir fragen gleich nach dem
antikörper test auch frau bringt man hat
simons wer gilt heute als geheilt gilt
heute als geheilt werde das krankenhaus
verlässt nicht automatisch wärmen uns
gerade heute morgen noch gedanken
darüber gemacht wie schaffen wir
eigentlich kapazitäten in die die
krankenhäuser auch menschen entlassen
können die noch als positiv gelten
auch da gibt ja das lka ganz klare
vorgaben vor wir telefonieren die leute
auch ab tatsächlich und und finden dann
raus haben sie noch symptome und so
weiter es gibt keine frei testung mehr
das muss man auch ganz klar sagen das
bedeutet für viele leute auch wieder
eine unsicherheit
und es bedeutet aber auch dass wir bei
diesem telefonat dass wir dann mit den
menschen führen nach einer gewissen zeit
auch an der ärztliche expertise brauchen
die noch einmal einschätzen kann sind
die menschen wirklich symptomfrei können
wir jetzt wirklich sagen sie können als
geheilt gelten das ist aber eine
wichtige zahl der momentan gelten als
geheilt das ist auch in den in den
medien eine immer wieder nachgefragte
zahl und wir müssen damit aber natürlich
auch sorgfältig umgehen da
unsicherheiten sind das schlimmste
situation genauso das ist mir eben noch
so auch als ganz wichtig gekommen wenn
wir viel testen wir müssen vorher auch
klar haben das schnell die ergebnisse
kommen
wir können das mittlerweile bei uns die
leute rufen an kriegen am nächsten tag
spätestens einen testtermin und haben 24
bis 48 stunden später ihr ergebnis wir
hatten eine kurze zeit zwischendurch
wurde es mal ein paar tage länger
dauerte das war ein ganz unglücklicher
zustand da menschen wirklich zu lang
geraten so lange warten müssen auf oder
wir haben sehr hart daran gearbeitet
sehr schnell dafür eine verbesserung zu
sorgen und das war auch wichtig das ist
gelungen aber das war ganz wichtig bei
unsicherheit vertragen die leute nicht
verbringt mal stichwort antikörpertest
es ist wichtig ist irgendeiner und wann
ist einer dieser tests massentauglich um
nachzuweisen ich bin wirklich immun ich
bin geheilt oder ich bin ohne dass ich
überhaupt wusste durch durch corona ja
da freuen sich nicht nur die modellierer
bei den daten sondern natürlich auch die
betroffenen und da kann ich ihnen nur
zustimmen die werden gerade validiert in
den diagnostik- laboren die mir erstmal
ganz klar zeigen ist der test spezifisch
und kann nicht dem test vertrauen denn
gegen sie schon sagen wenn der test
sagte die person hat antikörper aber das
stimmt gar nicht ist das fatal denn dann
schicke ich die person wieder ins
pflegeheim als pfleger und dabei hatte
sie die infektion gar nicht also das
müssen wir verhindern aber das läuft und
ich bin sicher dass wir in einem monat
schätze ich mal tests haben die wirklich
validiert sind daran sind wir in der
lage herr braun zu massen screenings
also um genau dafür zu sorgen die
menschen die diese informationen haben
die können ja dann nach einem test eben
auch wirklich in anführungsstrichen
wieder an die front die können irgendwie
arbeiten können sich um andere menschen
kümmern
man werden wie massen screenings machen
kann so wenn der test so valide ist dann
streben wir an sehr schnell dann
unmittelbar eine repräsentative
stichprobe zu machen um überblick zu
haben
wie groß dieser anteil der bevölkerung
ist und wie lange frau open halten geht
es dahin noch dieses gefühl von einer
leichten macht aus dass wir bestimmte
dinge eben nicht so schnell kriegen wie
wir sie haben wollen egal wie viele
millionen oder milliarden weder auf den
tisch legen
deswegen von der gesellschaftlichen
stimmung und vom beitrag jedes einzelnen
ab als der europäische ethikrat hat
seine stellungnahme nicht umsonst
genannt europäische solidarität und
schutz der grundrechte in der kurve 19
pandemie
diese solidarität die müssen wir jetzt
beweisen und krise heißt ja von der wort
herkunft her entscheidung und scheidung
und glaube wir müssen uns alle jeder
einzelne für sich entscheiden wie er
sich jetzt verhält und wir das mit
durchdrehen
zum wohle von uns allen und auch wenn es
noch etwas länger dauert bin ich der
überzeugung dass wir das schaffen
frau professor brinkmann wir hatten sie
vor acht wochen hier schon bei uns in
der sendung was war für sie das was bei
ihre lerngruppe was war das
überraschendste dass sie verstanden
haben über dieses neue outfit 19
das überraschende war dass es sich so
schnell verbreitet dass es sich sehr
anders verhält als das sars virus was
2002 sein unwesen trieb und dass wir es
nicht so eindämmen können saß einst
konnte eingedämmt werden weil es den den
patienten wirklich sehr krank gemacht
hat und er ist nicht noch ohne symptome
frei herumgelaufen und da war dann schon
tot
der war schon im krankenhaus zumindest
gleich noch nicht tot aber im
krankenhaus ja und isoliert und es gab
ja auch da sehr viele infektionen in
krankenhäusern wie bis jetzt auch sehen
aber dass dieser dieses virus sich jetzt
so leicht verbreitet das war vor acht
wochen noch nicht so über absehbaren
fragen wir herrn professor brockmann
noch mal nach wiederum nicht mehr
lernkurve sondern wird man irgendwann in
einer ihrer kurven in einem ihrer
modelle sehen können wie sehr die
entscheidungen der politik und die
maßnahmen die es heute gibt tatsächlich
zur eindämmung geholfen haben und davon
ist auszugehen dass wir auf jeden fall
entscheidungen dann zeitverzögert sehen
in dem prognosen aber auch einfach in
den daten die wir mit den modellen
erklären also eine retrospektive werden
wir sachen sagen können dann sind wir
auch hinterher flüge vielen dank ich das
nicht bei der runde ganz herzlich
bedanken für heute und gebe zu markus
lanz der unter anderem die
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern zu gast hat manuela schwesig
nämlich und wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen
schon am kommenden
sonntag wieder um 22 uhr 25 kommen sie
gut durch diesen abend und bleiben wie
gesund
[Musik]